last question today david why are older
voters
abandoning trump last week you you
talked about why
rural white older voters like trump but
now they're abandoning him why is it
basically three reasons appear to be
what's going what's really
hurting donald trump in the last week
this is new
before this week we knew trump's
handling of coronavirus was hurting him
in general
and hurting him with older voters
trump's handling of the economy
as a result of coronavirus meaning the
economic destruction was worse than it
had to be because of trump's mishandling
of
coronavirus that is hurting trump with
older voters but we now in addition
have the issue of debate performance the
post-debate polls by donald trump
the post-debate polls that account for
donald trump
trump's performance in the debate are a
disaster for trump
specifically among older voters older
voters in some polls
are no longer even the demographic group
age-wise
that most supports trump there's a new
poll i
think it was the cnn poll from this week
where
the under 35 crowd is actually
trump's strongest group from the
standpoint
of age and what's going on is that for a
lot of older folks
coronavirus is not abstract certainly if
you're in a nursing home
and you see people dying and you see the
chaos
it is not numbers you check once a day
it is very real
if you simply know people not
nursing home related who aren't doing
well and of course
because it disproportionately affects
older folks those are the folks most
likely to have
friends and people in their circle that
are suffering directly
and then you see trump go on television
and say it's like a flu
it's no big deal we've turned the corner
our mark we're getting great marks
you see the obvious lies and you know
well you know
blanche died and joe died how is trump
saying this your friends are in icus um
that is going to create a problem for
you and then when on top of it
you start looking you know at your
retirement account or you're on a fixed
income or
trump's talking about cutting funding to
social security by a payroll tax
deferral
it's not good and pretending that this
was a hoax
was a very bad idea the statistics don't
lie we said in may
when trump started transitioning into we
beat it
that that might work in june and july
but it's not going to work forever and
it's not been working
and then you add to the fact that
hillary clinton was less liked than joe
biden
joe biden by and large particularly
for uh older white folks
is much more likable than hillary
clinton he's the type of guy
most people would like to sit down and
just talk to
many older voters would identify with
joe biden
guy who grew up working class likes
trains
has suffered significant personal loss
and so on and so forth
then you look at trump and he's just a
rude disgusting guy who yelled the
entire debate
so all of that together tells us
seniors are paying attention they're not
willing to die
for the economy like the what was his
name dan
roberts or dan patrick the lieutenant
governor of texas said early on in this
thing
and they're paying attention they're
paying attention to what's going on
trump already going into all of this was
doing less well with seniors than many
previous republicans had done
now it's gotten even worse he's got the
latest polls in the last
96 hours are very very bad and hopefully
every single one of these groups will
completely repudiate donald trump
in a brutal brutal defeat but it's up to
us to make it happen and we're going to
try to do that exactly
and we will continue pushing next week
and the week after
and the week after that and then
hopefully we'll have a new
president-elect
we have a great bonus show for you today
remember
you can get instant access not an hour
from now
not 20 minutes from now instant access
to the bonus show
by becoming a member at joinpakman.com
or a patron at patreon.com
pakman show